afternoon everybody and welcome once
again to Android developer relations
office hours this is the emea edition
coming to you from the middle of the
afternoon in the middle of the week in
the middle of the summer in the middle
of Europe so I'm based out of munich
germany i'm also joined by naked matt in
london UK hello oh yeah everyone and
we're here to talk about android
application development with you and
with that we will see if anybody wants
to join us live in the Hangout and if
everybody is going to be shy and not
join us live in the Hangout then we'll
talk through the questions that were
sent an advance to the google moderator
so it was anybody in the Hangout
nobody's in the Hangout perhaps we'll
give them a minute or two I'm inviting
people but I abscess is being a little
bit sorry playing ball with me right now
so I think let's just jump straight to
the moderator and cover some of the
questions that were pre submitted and
we'll try and hope you get some live
participants later on if that's cool
let's do that so we have a oh my my
moderator link is not showing my
responses to the question so I look at
it as smells okay we have a question
from Mitchell in Denmark and he's he's
been on a tear on this topic lately
which is specifically when will all the
developers not just the top developers
be able to respond to user reviews or to
respond to comments and user reviews in
the Google Play application store his
concern is that by only allowing top
developers to respond to comments it's
effectively hurting everybody who's not
a top developer so that's what Mitchell
wants to know and my response to him
basically was that this feature was only
just rolled out and the people who run
the Google Play application store will
evaluate what to do with that feature as
they as they review the feedback comes
in based on the early based on the early
responses that we get from having the
top developers participate in it so
that's my answer maybe you guys want to
to offer your perspective on the issue
no I thinking exactly right like it's a
new feature we're rolling out we're
running out studies that we get it right
really like it it's not like we're
trying to hold stuff back from you guys
and just try to get it right and it's
through that that so if we're gonna
screw it up we're gonna screw it up for
the top developers ha ok let's move on
then to the next question the moderator
during io 2012 which happened this year
you announced that the paid applications
assets will now be protected in other
words the application will be encrypted
before it's sent to the device will this
feature be available for free apps using
an application purchasing more generally
can we provide you brahim with
directions regarding apks data
protection well the data protection just
takes that the data protection is simply
that the Google Play Store encrypts the
APK with a device-specific key so that
that APK can only be decrypted by these
specific device that the APK is sent to
i do not know if they plan to extend it
to free applications with an application
purchasing but i would suspect that it's
a lot less important because when you're
selling a paid application your your
money stream is based on controlling
which actual copies of the APK gets sent
out and where they go when you use in
application billing your monetizing
during runtime from any copy of the
application that's hitting the billing
server so it you don't really have a
vested interest a monetary interest in
restricting which devices the
application runs on you just want to
make sure that every running copy of the
application is able to buy from your
instance of the in application or
interesting online store did that make
sense that I ramble too much no I think
I did you hit the nail on the head
without now
so it may be that it may be that they
will extend it to I AP apps in the
future who knows but at the present time
I think they're covering the important
basis first I see we have our first live
participant in the call a new face that
I think maybe we haven't seen before oh
and there's also L something I out how
you're doing a spiky didn't get out you
so what's what's new with you in the
last week I playing around with network
service discovery in jelly bean very
interesting little addition basically
lets applications running on the device
say that they can offer services and
other applications can dynamically
discover services running on other
devices on the same Wi-Fi network that's
pretty cool so what it in body without
you got any ideas I've been messing
around just with a simple couple of
collaborative chat application
collaborative drawer applications so so
you're sitting in a session or something
at a conference everyone in the
conference can have a chat and they can
find each other by the network service
discovery system but also just shared
whiteboard so sitting in a meeting or
something like that people discover in
other devices use a nexus 7 or a similar
jelly bean enabled device to use a
collaborative whiteboard on the pad and
then walk away with it and after the
meeting everyone's got a copy of it very
nice Rachel I had a friend who tried to
build a company around this concept
several years ago and he had it all
working again straight up Java and I
seem to recall it took him many months
to develop each aspect of the service
how many months have you been on this l
I've been on it about two days and the
network service discovery thing took me
all about two hours because the javadocs
are all up as part of android com and it
all looks very simple and it works as it
should it's a sample code is silent as
well did you just die so there's a
sample flow chart but giving us
something I'm just playing around with
you might see some sample code appearing
on get up soon
excellent wow that's brilliant yeah I
like your new studio by the way oh we
are normal room was busy so we were just
in a room next door Thorne was squatting
it I know so we've got no androids
climate like trying to break out the
window behind us unfortunately this week
I think you've all got thinking I've got
pretty posh digs compared to my phone
booth here I'm in a about a one and a
half by 2 meter room here it is I called
a toilet I think I would have more room
if i were there something i said a
really awesome article about like the
dissecting how the earth encryption
works going back to the apt no just
talking to last night and i'll talk to
just now i just read it last night it
was really deep died they actually gone
through the the jelly bean sauce that's
been open source they've been gone
through there and the package manager or
package manager service in fact to see
you know how it is implemented and what
it means is it was a really interesting
read I'll try and find the link and post
it in the end announcement coins I'm
doing a quick little search to see if I
can bring it up in the meantime should
we maybe take another look at the
moderator see what we've got queued up
yeah um so it's like cats and Bristol
wants to know noticed in jellybean that
the render script graphics API has been
deprecated and we talked about this
before I remember if this is a new
question rollin I think it was a new one
mr. was used for things like the video
wall on YouTube page turning effects in
google books etc what should we use
instead open jail will this healthy
required performance i would say it's a
it's pretty much a slam dunk that opengl
would have the required performance
because that's about I think that's
pretty pretty much about as good as you
can get is to program an OpenGL
particularly if you do it using the NDK
we have any other any other options for
high-performance graphics absent
renderscript graphics I guess not really
another thing to keep in mind though is
also that now canvas drawing is hardware
accelerated by default so you should be
able to get much higher performance out
of campus drawing than you ever used to
be able to back in pre ICS versions of
Android yeah absolutely that veneer you
get to the hardware the more performance
you didn't get and but perhaps less
possibility so yeah running like playing
you know directly OpenGL is going to be
the most before thing you can really do
but you know if you try and get right
into the optimizations of different
graphic cards and so on and let you know
changing the order in which you could
make like gel calls and so on you get
the most performance but you know then
you kind of might lose a little bit of
possibility so you might want to take a
look at doing the level up so yeah I'd
like you say Sparky using are you know
Tilly drawing pipeline and turning on
the hardware acceleration yeah i think
the the hardware independence and the
sort of boilerplate less simplicity of
render script was really nice but i
understand that the feedback received by
the the graphics team both from within
the android development team and also
from the external developer community
was the demand wasn't there to keep that
api going right let's see i see Nick you
came up with a a link for that the
article and you ll did i'll post the
link but linked to the OpenGL
documentation at the moment the Hangout
doesn't seem to be a publicly posted on
the Android developers Google+ stream
which yeah I keep on trying to post it
and it keeps on saying failed my so i
think we are live like there's people
watching us on youtube i can see that so
it's just not announced you have people
joining do me to stick some of the links
in the event that i've put up for this
hand so we can get the comments up
running let me try just doing a regular
host with the mounting i'm going to
paste in the link that Nick turned up
for the article about the application
encryption in jellybean noticed if
anybody is not having access to the
sidebar notes it's it's nellen cove
blogspot com then you can just search
using app encryption and jelly bean that
HTML that should be enough to do to gate
nickel this is going to be a quick hang
out of radicchio more people in the call
I know that I know that tall until I be
he told me that he wanted to be in the
call but he's using a mobile client so
there's there's a little bit of
uncertainty whether he can connect I
don't know if he's trying to get in I'm
following his dream and I can't see
anything coming up by hanging right but
I'm just doing a manual posting this new
place isn't isn't playing ball I see the
manual base can people see that energy
in it android-developers extreme yeah
yes excellent great no i'm also i'm onto
android developers but i'm not looking
at a very often cool so hopefully we'll
get a few more like participants now
that we've posted that link we have
someone else's phallus Christopher how
you doing if you're not able to talk
right now you can check out you are hey
sorry about the age hang I seem to be
having a bit of a problem posting it to
extreme so let's do it manually so yeah
there's no audio or video ok well
perhaps perhaps Christopher would like
to to type a question to us or or
compose a short essay on what's going on
while he's doing that maybe I'll take
another question from the moderator
things are reordering a little bit
regarding Arabic support I am planning
to have a nap not yet launched
translated into Arabic Arabic speaking
users may represent thirty or forty
percent of my target audience what
should buy min SDK be to fully support
this language I would say our you know
our support for right-to-left languages
is fairly new and still rapidly evolving
I previous to Ice Cream Sandwich a
really rough and and even now in
jellybean I'm sure it's going to get
better and better as we as we gradually
revise the OS but if you're looking at
reaching a practical number of users
with your application you probably need
to target gingerbread or folio that's
where the bulk of the users are and and
I think you just need to evaluate what
you can do with maybe arabic font
support and static text labels and maybe
forego some of the interactive things
like like accepting right-to-left text
input but try to try to see how much
functionality you can package into a
gingerbread row folio application API
ten or eight just to get the mass of
users behind your application it's also
probably worth pointing out that the
some manufacturers have different
support for right-to-left languages so
it's probably worth and getting hold of
the devices i expect the users to use on
the main and seeing if there's the
language they're using in particular is
supported on it yeah that's a really
good point I've had a number of chats
with the the developer from Tel Aviv
that I was referring to before at all
and he tells me that it's very common
for devices where he is to be localized
in the Hebrew even though the reference
version of those exact same devices that
comes out of Google say a nexus branded
device won't have it
yeah some of the carriers a day I think
even though the open-source guys like I
think the cyanogenmod community I think
about it some some support for I have to
think not be familiar it but i believe
that happen i think i think we've had
the ability to display static strings
again some of these scripts for much
longer than we've had the ability to
edit them say in user interactive text
fields so I say we have a full hang out
now we've been joined by a whole bunch
of guys do you want to is anyone want to
jump in and say hello and talk about
what you're doing asked us was just a
plus what's your honor on your mind hey
Chris do it tell us about photo oh yeah
it's just not wanting to done for a
while basically it's just basically a
facebook up later so I basically just
wanted a simple app that could upload
multi photos at once just a nice simple
way and I've kind of ah kind of messed
with knife any other day I mean so
looking at sort of the facebook app that
i created called Facebook camera which
is just a very simple native app just
legit basically we better sort of did
myself member so spent bacterias doing
it this you just from line floor last
food so there's some lessons oh just and
how many libraries did you out and forth
in the process well yeah I don't mind do
not those it's you know is no even make
any money it's not I'm doing for that
and and if I'm nothing make any money
off it I'm also just released most of us
for open source because it must be happy
yeah I mean you've already got a pretty
useful pull-to-refresh library in there
and those well it's an imageview that's
got pinched to shrink and those can do
this like an multi-touch zooming image
view and which other missiles but in
joisey most the coach that is crate
while just pinched off the old galleria
and so the old of really you know it's
open source exactly yeah that's the
whole point
yeah I see people doing pinch zooming
wrong especially like a lot of people do
it so if you're in the two finger
tracking modes if you're tracking a
pitch they don't actually do panning at
the same time like yeah like that it
really annoys me when you see an
implementation it doesn't do that it's
like we've open source code which shows
exactly how to do this like there are
you doing it wrong exactly yes are
having a good library which is kind of
test it and you know you use light is
brilliant so thanks for that and I was
interested actually in looking at you
conflicted some of the filters and
things that and the light box on top at
sauce oh how did you find that process
is that easy to do and yeah they are
resort released it as a library it's a
standalone app they've done so the code
that released isn't sort of usable in
itself to not be reusing locking than
this Easter now so on my created I am
spyder 14 Gil almost up megabit better
for libraries and but yeah the one thing
got found out that it's not
multi-threaded it's single threaded so
you can't do multiple filters or
anything any of this sort of effects or
cropping or resizing anything like that
I'm monton Fred's so you have to be
careful what Fred you use interesting
and a couple of a baseball that and like
it's about a library and it works well
so yeah it's good of them to share it
exactly do you want to post a comment in
the place that Nick put up with a URL to
so people can grab it if they want to
nice is this github.com / Chris Bane's
yeah so on that yeah if you placed a
link in the announcement of this hangout
post I've been planted will do and
that's all the Apache to license is it
yeah it's all patch
so with your photo album are you doing
anything similar to the instant upload
and stuff a lil do I haven't got around
to it yet but i will do I'm time to me
how to do it nicely so probably a
content server just stop service it runs
in the background well an ice cream
sandwich on words there's a broadcast in
10 no sir yeah there's a photo taken
broadcast mmm reactive treble is a
dependency source samsung anyone else
have changed all that because they've
got their own camera phone anniversary
sang-ok long time content sevens today
oh I've all do but I've never answer yet
hahaha but you do a file system watcher
which is watching on the end the DCIM
folder maybe I'll try that that's going
on so I'm doing Ashley feels happy but
it won't work yeah yeah Internet allows
one of my favorite features of google
glass and i guess it kind of preaching
to the converted on this hangout but
someone's more of a textbook using
aerial vehicle cool feature so who else
we've got live participants velocity who
has a android development question or
what's it tell us about something I've
been working on or has questions anyone
live when I speak up I stop picking on
people speak up or type up I have the
small problem i'm facing regarding a
resource ID I mean okay um I have
implemented something like a plug-in
kind of the feature for a keyboard a
application i'm writing and this case a
keyboard it can be extended there with
themes and other languages and layout
and stuff like that mmm
I've chosen to use attribute and style
built in to parse XML in external apks
and so something that I noticed is that
the IDS of the attribute change when i
add and remove the new attributes yeah a
generator that belt on right right and i
was wondering if there's a way to to
maybe set them or maybe a fixed input
value yeah you can try an external
resource so he eat this Xena IDs
resourceful where you can actually try a
custom resource and you can reuse that
idea whenever you need to and come with
a specific value one of the values still
generals at runtime is just that you can
still point to that I do and always it's
like actually Eric Martin ordered and my
problem it is actually I'm doing
something similar i use a set of
attributes which I in a separate file
and thus I labelled referenced those
their attributes so it works fine of a
44 now I can add and remove the
attributes as I wish it doesn't break
any old a packages but I it since it
generate their days at runtime at some
point the build chain could put that she
IDs and completely ruin my my old
against
seems to me like either you need to
depend on the strings the symbolic
values or you need to pin down your
numeric values somehow maybe capture
your your resource identifiers once and
just save them off as text constants or
your static finals or something like
that or if the opportunity to use a
content provider so that your plugins
can query the main application and get
the IDS back hmm maybe one that sounds
like a lot of work um content providers
aren't all that huge what you can do is
you can even use reflection if you know
the values of them so you can then
reflect into the ID database or that the
ID class and you can pick out the ids
from that in your main application
return the by the content providers
interface for separating your your
plug-in from your actual main
application um ok but that one want to
help me save the old plugins ok I have
something like 30 plugins they already
published hmm so I need something that
either is fixed value of the resource
already and then actually have no idea
the other option I was thinking about
was to a him move back to a actual
estimable a parsing with the XML pull a
horse similar way that's not such a bad
solution really I mean it's not quite as
performant it's just looking at a number
but you know realistically how often do
you have to do it I mean you parse the
XML once when you load the plug-in or
maybe even when you install it and then
you're pretty much done I think that
it's worth incurring a performance
penalty or something
that only happens you know once a day or
less okay okay so a you you don't you
don't for me you are not very familiar
with any way to fix the value of gaining
attributes there is there is a method to
do I'm trying to think what it is if
used in the AOSP source code for fixing
specific IDs and I have a feeling it's
either an annotation in a class or
there's a locker in the XML I try and
dig a URL for you and post it on the
Google+ stream post for this hangout if
I can find it okay great thanks kind of
just cry six list of ideas and them to
sign on the next map rather than using a
generator or did you just actually a
song integer they didn't catch you so
you create a list like an integer array
or integer values in XML and then just
assign the end as the idea rather than a
generated I do so I'm so dune at + ID /
whatever you just do other than if it'll
work I've top married still what is it I
guess you could have a mapping from the
generated IDs to just a fixed set of
ideas for that one particular plug-in
and then do that for you to plug in is
that what you're sort of getting at and
ok i will divest you this is a this is
an example a of the attributes if you
will go check out this file okay this is
how high I've declared the attributes if
you go about halfway into the file
you'll see something that code and
keyboard best view or something like
that and so each one of those the
attributes our automatic their ID are
automatically generated
it feels time and for now since it's
still 10 about something like then their
ideas were always the same hey but
they're generated at runtime so it might
someday great as an XML attribute msg ID
that seeped in the translations for the
framework for the core framework of
Android and the strings will use this
msg ID with the set value which appears
to fix that value I'm trying to find
whether it can be used in other
attributes but it looks like that might
solve your problem yeah that would be
great yeah I'm not too sure whether it's
a public API or not that's part of them
certainly looks worth following up on
anything I father's i'll post couple
links in the sidebar in the comments you
guys can carry on with with something
else great thank you later yeah is any
more live questions from people in the
hang up over gotta stop picking on some
people that Leslie's join us hello Emil
and someone else is new to their video
I'll see you up I need live questions
you want to join me we just hanging out
to chat
I'll take the deadly silence is it too
much we jump back into the Moto X's
study let's jump back to the moderator
I've got a couple of new questions that
came in late I haven't had time to think
about them so maybe I'll skip forward to
the ones that I've that I've already
left intuitive how much longer until the
winter 12-4 has official support for
building Android and what types of
problems should i expect if I beginning
compilation well that's a good question
i can build android on my a bunch of
system but it's not a Tulpa a horse- an
older version of ubuntu but i will say
that the biggest obstacle that i had in
building Android was getting the right
java compiler in there specifically the
the open source java compiler that went
to you says by default is is not the
right one you need to actually have the
official some Java Sea 1.6 or higher
compiler so um you know make sure you
get that in there and get all the rest
of the dependencies and I see no reason
why wouldn't work unless there's
something special about the winter 12
that I don't know there's something
special about 12 12 the heat I know look
II ubuntu 12.04 is currently only
supported in the experimental state on
the master branch of the android open
source repository their instructions on
setting up your build environment on
source android com that specifies some
of the things you need but there was a
compiler upgrade as for the c compiler
as well as some library upgrades which
can cause issues building on 12 point 0
for specifically best place to go is on
to the android building mailing list and
have a search because there are quite a
few people who've done it there are
quite a few particularly posting up
their experiences and the tricks you
need to solve the issues alright that
sounds like a very authoritative answer
so nice to know that there's there's
people out there who have time to do the
things that i don't have time to look
into
what do you build and how you build on
OSX I build on OSX but I need to do some
tweaking and I also use Ubuntu 10.04
which is the current recommendation for
ice cream sandwich from jelly bean I
think that's a pretty good suggestion to
I mean since all the versions of window
are always available for download just
tell somebody if you're really keen on
building Android install of our older
version there's a lot of people use
virtualbox parallels vm wear something
like that to just pop up a virtual
machine with 10-point 04 on so they
don't have to do a complete reinstall
the main thing for ice cream sandwich
jelly bean and in fact pretty much
everything since froyo is it needs to be
a 64-bit installation you can't use a
32-bit installation reliably ok well I
do build the android firmware in a
virtual machine from time to time and
although it's quite slow it's not
unbearably slow but it takes less than a
day easily to do it will hold all of
everything in meditation ok if I told
you the full build on my machine takes
about 30 minutes you can get my own
differences mark what are you running
our macro oh yeah it's 16 or 32 gig
three SSDs mac pro oh my god oh it's
part of what I do for a living so having
a fast build means I could spend more
time fixing problems in less time seeing
what builds break wow that works this
one hell of an excuse to constantly
upgrade lutely distrusted it don't need
any heating new house nope you'd see
that every time the Machine goes on the
cat suddenly appear and find the best
place to sleep is on top of it Wow I do
have to say hi how you doing Jack
waiting so just left all right shall we
don't see any questions in the sidebar
nobody's looking at singleton a little
vibrator google i/o it was announced
that google play instead of installing
the whole application only the changed
part of the application will be
downloaded from from google play to the
device when can we expect this update
from the google play store well i don't
know and i don't think it matters
because it's completely transparent to
us the developers there's really nothing
for us to do so we can simply either let
it happen or not another question just
came in and I nuri for jelly bean I
don't know when they are but the sources
are up there and if you're really that
impatient you can you could try to jump
the gun and build your own version
what's this for I'm Teddy B Nexus S they
want binaries for nexus s the gelatin
that would be that would be one of those
unannounced unannounced products things
that we don't really talk about it would
be after it starts shipping out to
devices that's the common answer that
comes out jbq on that question is once
you see devices start being updated in
the fields or public devices after that
you'll start seeing the factory images
of yes factory image yeah definitely
it's usually the drivers come along 14
agreements have been reached and it's
usually after that happened with Nexus S
at least we have if i recall correctly
we have better access to hardware level
stuff than we have had on some of our
previous devices and we have better
ability to generate updates to it and
used to have yeah that pretty much seems
to be the case there were some licensing
issues with the cdma one that been
sorted out now so everything looks like
it should be nice and buttery is the
jelly bean user interface
yeah I think it should fly on the nexus
s i think if i remember correctly there
was actually more kind of ram available
given the screen size so I'm actually I
believe a baby should run pretty well
you're saying that the pixel count on
the Nexus S relative to the strength of
its GPU and its buses is more favorable
than on the Greeks pretty much bilbao
fill rate bound and i think we had a
bigger than life well those less of an
inch in the neck success due to the much
we're each pixel and stay compared to
something like advice Nexus it's the
same GPU the nexus in the garden is its
power they are isn't it Nexus S I
believe I remember oh let's check left
driver sitting the same thing yes yes
540 that sounds about right so lines
kinda thrown a quick question doesn't
really know how this works hey that's it
thank you sorry I'm an Android developer
making a bunch of apps but I've got a
bug right now before now from doing that
only occurs on for you and so I you know
works i can get it I can reproduce on
the emulator and it kind of cured so it
actually happened on the device so you
talk about images can I can I find a
froyo image I don't want to build it
really I kind of get it for you image in
and flash it onto the google i/o nexus s
man so you simply not an ex success if
you have a nexus one you could probably
do it I do have a nexus I do have the
nexus one here but inches dad I don't
know it doesn't turn on anymore I got
another battery from I was hot but that
didn't help so did you say you've tried
the emulator already yeah I've tried
yeah I can reproduce the bug on the
equator I'm just curious if it actually
happens on a device to it was a really
weird bug where it couldn't find a
resource and the fix was to move an XML
drawable out of you know one of the
drawable dash you know hdmi hei
directories to what to draw
so it's like a weird bug right so I
destroys that actually happened on a
real bill that's really wait but ya
can't happen a real devices but that
doesn't sound like one of them it was on
the emulators happened on the emulator
right if I didn't think it happier on a
real device I what ideally what I do is
find it for you image out there in flash
now one of the plethora of devices i
have um it wasn't by any chance that
durable was in some of my xhdpi because
free wouldn't have been aware of that
tag with it that is what did Susan yes
yeah I'm sorry go ahead so if the
drawables in xhdpi I don't think froyo
would have been aware of that bucket
size at which point I don't think it
would have checked and then used that as
the best fit drawer all right and it
won't automatically down scale so that
this was an XML resource of this project
I got into it was like a I don't know
just some drama XML grovel right oh yeah
just none of it the resources system
wouldn't even know to look in the xhdpi
directory it wouldn't know such a thing
existed well no it only existed in the
draw ball I think it was hdpi directory
and not in the drawable directory and so
when it when I want to inflate the
layout if it crashed exception was that
I couldn't find the file confined xml
file city existed hdb on partner
it only existed in high DPI folder yeah
and a couple others hdpi hepi dash v
nine ish epi dash v 11 h ldpi he didn't
exist in source if you run on the voice
where it wouldn't fit then he would
throw that because he can't find it I
well I rent on the emulator and I guess
it can find it one of those directories
or what the doc said for XM says for XML
drawables is to only put him in the draw
whole directory not the drawable dash
you know density directly it sounds to
me like he was working as intended
really like if it was only like a the v9
like you're saying which means that that
draw won't be available on gingerbread
and beyond like yeah right yeah right so
yeah so maybe it was just yeah what
about like hdpi though they should have
found it on fri
yeah that would work ever since complex
six only if it was on an hdb I device so
I'm just gonna make a biggest function
i'm assuming you're not an experienced
from android programmer yeah no I've got
quite a bit of stuff but I'm done to
wait on the resource because the result
selectors depend on the device as well
as the OS exactly so it's all right so i
use the emulator right and it is where I
got the bug is where I want to actually
try it on a device and you had it set up
so it should have picked from that
resource directory yeah cool yeah so um
ok so we've got to the bone of it yeah
it sounds like EV shouldn't be like
bringing that horrible is that your
layout should be referencing it if you
know that drug shouldn't exist on the
older platform or and yet that generally
XML drawables will go just in a straight
drawable folder and then they had the
clouds computation yes is there
something emporia well well we just will
not pick up the throughout the xml
drawable like or it all the look for it
in the drawable directory no no that'll
well if it's not just like you couldn't
see that drawable but that kind of like
a directory in which it really existed
because of some kind of version qualify
it sounds like to me but you know how to
see but as for your question about
testing it like no can we just flush a
an image if it's in exists but you could
look at sound like test droid if test
Roy calm which will let you have like
remote access to a real device so you
can upload an apk and have executed and
get results back and so I think they
have a free program which that you you
know do so many tests over a period of
time and before you have to pay the side
doing it Otis but like you know if you
want to do the random or test you can
select a froyo device and you know bring
your apk on that and see what happens oh
thank you calm this ever son yeah I'm
thinking that the you know Nick and L I
think you're pretty much had it with new
XML drawables should probably not go
into directories that are DDI related
that those those those DPI suffixes are
really forbid map data
yeah okay just been joined by sterling
Goodell do you have anything you want to
talk about any questions or you want to
discuss what you're doing with Android
these days I'm ahead a question well
sort of a discussion point can you hear
me all right by the way silly okay just
checking um that I had put on the
moderator queue for the the North
American hang out but this is more
convenient time for me as it turns out
um and it's basically to do with
semantic zoom you know the the concept I
mean in the ice cream sandwich calendar
app you can pinch to zoom and expand
your your appointments over the day and
then contract them back down and it's
kind of similar to what has been done
with the new notifications in jelly bean
but it's a different UI for it there to
expand it you take two fingers and drag
down you can jizz off you can pinch to
close but not too open I survived late
is not deadly but well I haven't got it
to work yet if it is I just watched the
google i/o talk about that today and I
seem to recall they said that several
different affordances wrong they said
yeah it was I said okay um let's nodeb
answers my question and because I'm I've
got an app i see i was pinching
vertically that seemed to make sense to
separate the rose there's not free or
four different ones than that you can
not do some weird to fingering yeah
there's all sorts of weird yeah yeah
which I wasn't too sure about when I
think to finger drag up and down that
near the easiest way to go in fact I
never actually I rarely actually expand
or collapse them I tend to just work
from the top and triage it's like as it
also expands the top one but not sure I
think the reason I bring it up is I've
got an absent that semantic zoom would
be quite useful in and I'm wondering if
there's a recommended you I affordance
to implement given there seems to be
some some variants in the Google Apps
really yeah well if pinch tends to be
like the you know standard zooming in
and out I think that would probably my
pervert preferred first option I think
the reason we investigate other gestures
and the notifications is simply like a
you know space reasons that you know
it's reasonably small tat targets so I
would definitely look at an pinching as
a festival for that works you sure I
think it would ya okay okay thanks I
think especially things like yeah you
know is such a accepted gesture now in
maps and browsers photo galleries and so
on but you know I definite ride it first
okay there's some chat going on in the
sidebar never saw them and some of the
stuffs about the nexus given out I 00
skip that okay wish I could have had one
of those because anyone else yes Google
employees we do not get the schwag woof
you one for a google glass developers
kit oh love one of those as well and
then there's a does anyone else have a
question that they want to talk about
live in the hang over the last few
minutes so I'll just jump back here just
bawl you out since you asked okay so
this is that the resource thing so just
to clarify just to make sure I getting
this right so the the XML drawables
removed from the LDP I mdpi and xhdpi
and part of the draw whole directory and
the it's a standard for it you know 2.2
emulator image I me and so just change
it just moving over to dramas with
directory everything for client I could
find at that point so I guess is that
does that make sense to everyone nothing
yeah he likes Bucky said it's like it
degree didn't make any sense to have a
xml durable which has no concept of
density in a density specific all other
parents to work to help li stonn
gingerbread it up I think that's more of
a happy accident and by design yeah
they're enough thank you know it I had a
question you guys just returned office
hours mean and big t guys does it make
sense or it's just a weird American
google thing I think hangout will be
better just hang out yeah
android-developers hang out office hours
definitely resonates with me because
it's this is a term that we used back in
my university days when we wanted to
talk to a professor or a TA okay I think
office hours also implies that you're
you know you're here with somebody sort
of more official rather than just a
developer hang out good be anybody ah
the only thing that offers as that comes
to my mind it sounds kind of like a drop
in thing I don't know if that's what you
want to put try as but it sounds like
you'll be running it over a long time
people drop in and drop out and there
may be times when you you're just on
your own here ah do want it to be drop
in but at the same time I don't know if
we necessarily want to project the image
of you know we three we are the voices
of authority in who she likes yeah
except our divine guidance okay I think
much more conversational is what I would
want how about making the use of the
hang out and saying hold your hand up if
you think officers is a fine name I just
need to implement that you look up
things I can see what other people
computing I've sad read the comments on
YouTube but I don't wanna do that Chris
doesn't get extra points for wearing a
pirate hat during that I did not tear on
mine I babies I guess occur if the point
is then we hope you guys have been
enjoying these office hours hangout and
we definitely wanna expand it more like
the guys to the US are doing we have a
bit of a bigger team better setup which
replicate that hair other set up at
least but we want to do some more kind
of like app reviews and you know branch
out from just a question and answer
session into like best practice and
interviewing some people and you know
got some great developers here in Europe
that I'd love to kind of like have the
guests kind of thing on the show and
talk about the bit where they're doing
but if you guys have any suggestions
about the content you want to hear from
her like you know what's the most useful
to you is it this kind of questions and
answer and having some direct access you
know by are us till I get get you know
questions answered order to do or do you
want to hear from us really anyone's
going suggestions and we're all is I
think this is great as a developer but
as a as a thing running into the weekend
I'd love to see some app reviews so I've
got things to play with and get
inspiration from so you you watch the
shows that they're doing in the US the
moment be kind of a Friday app review in
the games review I watched the YouTube
feed afterwards and get some of those
but it'd be cool if you guys could
highlight some of the local content and
some of the local talent in terms of
developers who are producing good apps
so you like it's like a showcase of
interesting stuff or do you like it for
the tips and tricks you pick up during
the review or like you for the showcase
it's something that I it's a good way to
find a set of applications that are a
kind of good examples of how to do
things and what user friendly and so
that we can see some recommendations for
kind of things we should look to
implement and our apps in terms of user
interface guide or not even guidelines
with user interface tricks and tips to
make things very simple to interact with
cool so you be thinking multiple shows
one show with some some questions there
I asked oh I definitely wanna get into
some to map reviews it's the kind of
thing we experiment with if you have our
live sessions before which I think stuck
on down really well and can I throw a
suggestion yeah why not do the app
review and then i have the developers
questions hang up straight after it so
the guys who've written the applications
could hang around and get questioned
during the developers hang out yeah
we're sort is running back to back yeah
yeah so that way you can see what
they've done you can see the cool things
and then ask them how they did it and if
they got any tricks into it
who ya ghous just coolin it bus 16
tanning any of the requests will hat
small bear anything out there hey guys
go is good yeah we're still I think
we're still working on the delivery
mechanism for EB r you found kinder
stout Sparky so there must be other
things you can provide it's in low light
you know where I was when I found that
right in the UK now isn't that was in
Buxton blimey cool okay well sorry that
we were a bit late starting today were
having a couple of and challenges with
the Hangout unfortunately which is where
the announcement post went out a bit
late but I'm glad that we managed to get
and a good quorum have people joining us
and then a bunch of people falling low
on YouTube and so also hi to the people
watching later I guess but for now
that's a wrap for this week's and it
speaks office hours as you guys seem to
enjoy being closed so thank you very
much for joining us and as always feel
free to submit questions into the
moderator and for next week's and hang
out and until then we'll have a good
week yeah thanks guys think oh my gosh
hey